well brian and denise today
city state and local officials including
those from the department of homeland
security had a security briefing to talk
about the measures in place not just at
ground zero for the memorial tomorrow
but all around new york city and they
advise the public as well as anyone
watching with
ill intentions
security is going to be massive
today flowers were being placed at the
memorial pools alongside the names of
those who perished 20 years ago
one of those who never returned was
kevin pfeiffer a firefighter and brother
of fdny chief joseph pfeiffer i saw this
plane race down the hudson river at a
low altitude
it disappeared behind some buildings
and then i saw the plane
aim
and crash into the world trade center
pfeiffer headed for the towers and began
giving out assignments he gave his
brother the order to evacuate and rescue
anyone left in the building for a few
seconds we just stood there
and we wondered if each of us was going
to be okay we took his unit engine 33
and that was the last time i saw my
brother
in engine 33. heroes were born out of
the ashes that day and as those heroes
are being remembered the watchful eye of
a terrorism task force is in place to
keep the city safe so on the eve of this
anniversary the city's security remains
a top priority we will leave no stone
unturned to protect the individuals we
have pledged to represent
so it was important that i come here in
person
to thank the individuals who are working
round the clock to identify
and potentially thwart any threats
both the governor and the nypd making
sure this 20th remembrance is a safe one
there are no specific incredible threats
to to new york city but we also
understand the time that we're living in
and to stand united that we will do
everything possible to protect new
yorkers never forget
it's hard to believe that it's been
almost 20 years from that day
i can tell you that it would be
impossible to forget
impossible to forget because since 9 11
there have been 51 additional plots or
attacks against new york city according
to the nypd half of them within
the last five years
in jersey city new jersey i'm craig
treadway brian and denise back to you
craig thanks for that report tonight and